so I would have met for most people
being able to be part of a Pixar movie
Disney this cool character yeah dream
come true so I'm just curious what you
paid to be in the movie okay I'm so glad
you mention it Steve I paid a lot my
savings is depleted but it's worth it
it's a I will say I'm pretty overwhelmed
to be here I'm like I feel like 4k I'm
just kind of astonished all the time as
I said repeatedly I love the movie it's
so so good for you what is there because
doing this process I know it's years
yeah it's change along the way right
what is what is it like watching the
film for the first time are you sort of
surprised that like because you've
delivered so many lines yeah
well the cool thing is they when you do
a line it when you're recording it they
kind of do it a lot of different ways so
I really don't exactly know how they're
going to kind of put the puzzle together
when I see it so there's a lot of stuff
but also I'm sure you've heard this from
other people
you just get pages of the scripts I
really didn't know the whole story I
just kind of knew four keys journey and
so I didn't really know about kabooms
story I didn't know he was on a pinball
machine in the antique shop I didn't
really know about you know ducky and all
those kind of guys and so it's like it
was fun to see it and be like wow this
whole universe I had no clue that's so
interesting so really the big the third
you're just seeing the ground level
you're not really at 35,000 feet at all
oh no no no I'm not even in the ballpark
and also but I will say it helped with
four key because he's so ever he's such
a blank slate he knows nothing going on
so it's like everything that was coming
to me I I had to treat it like I know
nothing I don't know what I don't know
what they mean when they say Bo Peep I
don't know what a bo is you know I don't
know anything so it was fun to always
have that childlike curiosity with it
and you've done other voice work how is
it different doing something that Pixar
than other voice work if at all yeah it
is different there's typically you're
kind of in your own little
over booth there's a piece of glass and
all the kind of bigwigs on the other
side of the glass you record and then
everything goes quiet and then you're
just seeing these mouths talk about you
but you don't know what they're saying
so this insecurity just flushes over
your body but where the pics are you're
all in the same room there's a very kind
of collaborative feeling there's a real
family feeling and it's you have kind of
an ownership over you don't feel so
separated so I think that's a part of
kind of the tone that they create one of
the things about the the journey over
the course of years is that so many
things can change did you ever have what
was ever like something that didn't make
the film or something you were support
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
because it's I've heard there can be
drastic changes along the Adelman
process I what I just thought about is
like I remember when I was recording I
was in the middle of shooting beep the
first time and I'm sure I said some
things because I'm so used to the world
that they're like yeah we can't use that
in Toy Story so I'm sure there was a few
things cut out I really hope I mean
they're never gonna share it but I would
love it shouldn't like the the r-rated
like having some animation like an
internal thing that they don't know what
you think about for jeez so overwhelmed
you know when I'm overwhelmed a few
choice words come out so I'm sure in my
ad-lib I might have thrown some stuff
out just cuz I was used to that I'm beat
so they went one of the things is I
think for key and do kaboom are going to
be loved by fans there's already
merchandise all over the park is there
certain merchandise that you have seen
that you're like I need all of this it's
all the merchandise that I've seen I
need all of this because I'm still
trying to embrace the fact that I'm even
here so anytime like I got it I got a
pen if we're keepin the other day that
says I'm not a toy Hey
and I just can't get enough of it I saw
the suitcase with four key on it I was
like there's my suitcase you know I'm
just loving all of it
I believe you went into the park or
parks I saw you there exactly so I'm
curious which rides did you do that you
would recommend to others that are like
okay this is amazing
well you recommended avatar and we went
on twice and I I was blown away by that
and actually in all honesty that's the
only ride we did cuz I didn't have time
he gets an extra minute right yeah yeah
and or how much but he say thank you but
I but that's really the only one we did
and it was did you have you been on
soaring over California I have yeah and
it reminded me of that but it was just
like another level right um I I don't
know if you have the time to go on
anything else but there's other really
good rides which one do you like top
three would you say oh I'm the wrong
person for this but I got to tell you I
went on the frozen ride which I did not
think was gonna be all that and it is it
was all that it was surprisingly awesome
and I'll be very brief it's just shows
you the animatronics you can't but the
faces yeah real like a little bit the
cartoon come to life and I took me the
whole ride to figure out how they did it
totally worth doing they have they have
this little guy of forky that they put
on a screen that you're talking to and
it is the wildest and it's just like
it's like a hologram I mean talking to a
forky it's like it's wild what they can
do I know I'm out of time I just won't
ask you know but you're doing for Disney
Plus you're doing yes for key asks a
question yes
what can you for right now people won't
once they see the movie they're gonna
want this sure so what can you tease
about it um he just it just starts with
four key asking a question of all these
things that I as an adult should know
and I didn't know and of course I can't
remember any of them because we so long
ago but and then these Toy Story
characters come in and just kind of help
him explore the question and it's my
thing is it's such a simple concept but
it's questions that everybody might want
to ask and then there might be too
embarrassed to ask so they're short like
it's like Tourette's is it I think
they're like 5 to 10 minutes oh I cannot
wait oh I love it I love it yeah on that
note I gotta go I really mean it
Congrats
oh dude for ranked use and thanks for
the recommendation yeah go on some other
rides if you have time are you gonna be
able to get back to the park uh no